foreign
[Music]
it's been 20 years since Peter Jackson
took us to Middle Earth and 10 years
since we all asked to leave
now return to token's Grand moral
Universe where good Lives in Balance
with nature and evil destroys the land
in a blind lust for power and profited
brought to you by Amazon I wonder if the
orc slaves get free two-day shipping
the rings of power
foreign
witness the second age of Middle Earth a
time of relative peace but when Rebel
Spy Cassie and Andor oh sorry scoop's
got mixed up a lot of people to cover
witness the second age of Middle Earth
nope no that's next week's prequel
witness the second age of Middle Earth a
time of relative peace prosperity and
dramatic establishing shards when a
mysterious stranger appears from the sky
a mysterious stranger appears at Sea a
mysterious stranger appears on land and
three mysterious strangers go looking
for the other mysterious strangers one
audience will be asked to wonder who are
all these people and why should I care
look I can barely keep up with the ones
who aren't mysterious stop making me do
homework to watch TV you didn't say the
Hall of law was assembled by elros
himself
yeah
remember Galadriel well she's not Kate
Blanche yet this horse girl's got a
blade that moves as much as her mouth
doesn't you have the look of your father
and when her loyal kill Squad tries to
put this Elf on the Shelf she'll refuse
to step down until she can fulfill her
Destiny and lead her forces into an
active volcano all while being tricked
every step of the way but this Kirkland
brand Aragorn looks can be deceiving I
have had many names Sauron lives wait
that's Sauron come on he can't turn into
a giant eye he's too sexy
you see the minds of Moria now enter the
dwarf Kingdom of Gaza Doom where the
women may not have beards but they do
have pipes
and the accents are thick is that we
Mallards with the great vote the coins
from that cartoon program was there
anything else you wanted to ask about
did what is Prince Duran goes from
Alloys to allies with his BFF elrond a
diplomat with a permanent case of smirk
in this mining subplot about making
weapons of mass corruption what is it
you hope to craft that we all know are
going to be the Rings but boy do they
take their goods we time to get there it
would be smaller than previously
imagined like a ring a circular form
will be ideal just say ring two crowns
it'll need to be something
smaller just say it you know you want to
say it one object
for all Middle Earth see ring it's in
the name
this show is about so much more than
digging secret Minds it's also about
digging secret tunnels someone knocked
this passage something travel to the
Southlands with elf cop arendir and is
one true love a Healer lady this perfect
dude is the Dude Perfect of trick shot
archery
all right
but he must reckon with prejudice simply
because he spies on everything this
Village does from a massive guard Tower
together these two will repel the
attacks of Tommy Wiesel oh hi Mark while
trying to play some sensible boundaries
on the rebellious teenage kid is this
really so tragic no that's the Sea
Captain's rebellious teenage kid there's
a reason he came to us that's the Brandy
foot's rebellious teenage kid okay look
if you're gonna cram in 100 side plots
could you at least not copy and paste
all the side characters
follow the friendly Fun Size forestvana
known as the harfords who may look like
nice little Hobbits but their society is
built around making good time on an
eternal road trip so they'll leave you
to die in a ditch if you so much just
twist an ankle we're going to be left
behind into their Logans run as Society
Falls the mysterious being known only as
the stranger oh I know this one so the
stranger is when you sit on your own
hand until it goes numb and then no no
okay fine then he's probably Gandalf
dude only loves hanging out with short
people and smoking pipe weed and he's
all at a pipe weed
foreign
[Applause]
so get ready for a new take on Lord of
the Rings that isn't afraid to get
political not because of the black elves
if anything they should all be black
their Homeland is inside the sun because
it's a story where a terrorist from
across the sea knocks down two symbols
of Elven power they respond by invading
the middle e kill a bunch of Orcs who
had nothing to do with it and refuse to
leave until they suck up all the
underground resources and turned them
into red white and blue weapons wait are
we are we the baddies here
[Music]
starring the Gladys Knight a successful
rebranding effort Matt Smith in Orlando
Bloom in a blender during it and during
it and during it well there are those
who call me Tim
proto-baggins Samwise gamshee
Ewoks my eyes cigargos they do nothing
seven to nine years have been stationed
here it does not crack indeed Dr Wynn
Medicine Woman the drip Merchant he's an
angry elf more dork
do you have a moment to talk about our
Lord and savior Sauron and calling
respawns
right
[Applause]
lord of the Southlands
if you believe it
do you believe it
no but
Amazon presents the Lord of the Rings
the rings of power season one of five
galadriel's Origins Sauron begins
you know you can pinpoint the exact
moment where Warner Brothers defiles
token's corpse right here
I'm going to clip this audio for my text
notification buddy
Chang soon begged for mercy Kung Lao
granted him none
it three witches watch three watches
which which watches which watch History
doesn't remember blood it remembers
names